from the director of Legion comes priest
so like I mentioned priest is directed
by the director of Legion and you know I
hated Legion and I'll say right away
priest is not as bad as I thought Legion
was does that make priests good okay
here we go
so priest is a story of like this
alternate world where vampires and
humans have Ward Forever and priests
fought off the vampires and the vampires
have believed to be long since isolated
but a vampire attack happens and Paul
Bettany is like I'm gonna go take care
of this [ __ ] and the church is like new
you mustn't you cannot the Saint the
church thus sayeth the Lord
so Bettany's like yeah I'm gonna go kick
some ass you let me know when you're on
board with this [ __ ] and so then he
embarks and so now Paul Bettany is out
to go hunt down the vampires which are
really not like vampires they look like
those liquors from Resident Evil 2 which
I didn't like
I like vampires to look like vampires
these didn't look like intelligent
beings or anything like that it just
look like animals that you're supposed
to just wipe out I like the cool human
vampires you know the badasses which
brings us to Karl Urban he's like the
human vampire guy which I found kind of
cool but then I realized that the whole
tactic they're using on Karl Urban's
character is to surround him with a
bunch of shitty characters or characters
or vampire dogs to make him look cooler
it's like chicks when they go to a club
you know one chick will surround herself
with a bunch of less attractive chicks
to make her look all hot like you know
they described in Hall Pass that [ __ ] is
real though they really do that I think
that's what they did with Karl Urban in
this movie surround him with a bunch of
CGI vampire animals and it makes his
character look all cool and in depth
when in reality he fits right in with
this movie I think the problem is the
movies directed by a special effects
supervisor so it's like alright here's a
special effects scene I'm gonna do that
scene and all right here's another
special effects scene I will do that
seaming he doesn't know how to bridge
the - it was just like boom scene and
boom scene disjointed [ __ ] which there
is a scene where a dude falls off the
trip the Train is going like 78 parsecs
an hour's unease going fast it's trying
to make good time so you know this thing
is hauling ass dude falls off the train
is a human being he falls off the train
he rolls like once he's like ah he
stands up he's like oh well you know
alright let's try to catch up to that
train again I just think he would be a
skeleton on the ground with a streak of
skin and blood that was you know him
not not in the future I mean the
characters really mean nothing in the
movie like for priests are sent out by
the church to take out the main priest
that being said three of them get bubba
fetid and the other ones you know Maggie
Q she's the main chick if you're gonna
have a movie in which the bad guys are a
bunch of CGI dogs make the main
characters cool but now Paul Bettany is
like you know stoic like he was in
Legion and his sidekicks that one cocky
blond dude you know the guy he was in
burlesque he was also in Pandorum can't
think of his name to save my ass but
it's like the director was like all
right I want a han Solo type character
in this movie this is gonna be the Han
Solo and maybe that's how it was in the
graphic novel - I've never read the
graphic novel so I don't know but then
they get this dude who I don't blame for
the performance I just blame the script
because it's [ __ ] it's almost like the
guy was just like oh I'm gonna dress up
to be future cowboy and I'm gonna have a
bunch of future cowboy lines that
feature Cowboys are supposed to do
because you know that's me in this movie
I'm future cowboy so many times things
are going down then it cuts back to him
you're like oh yeah that dudes in this
movie I forgot why is he in this movie
then he goes back to Paul Bettany he's
thrown down with a bunch of CGI vampire
dogs and Maggie Q who's doing her thing
minutes go by and then it cuts back to
this dude you're like oh yeah that's
right that guy's she's still in this
movie why is he in this movie the story
gives a reason as to why he's in the
movie but he's not han Solo
so Paul Bettany was boring the sidekick
was like feature space cowboy [ __ ]
that I didn't buy my first thought
Maggie was on all right she was [ __ ]
too the script was disjointed the
villains sucked because there were no
real villains were just a bunch of CGI
dogs the main villain among the villains
had potential but still not great it's
like if Mad Max took a [ __ ] on Legion
and poured some of that weird science
potion stuff on and brought it to life
so I got to say it is it better than
Legion yes is it good enough to get
anything but dog [ __ ] nope not at all I
don't think Paul Bettany cares about
movies he's in at this point he's like
yeah I'm gonna pick [ __ ] movies it
doesn't matter because in the end I go
home and I bang Jennifer Connelly I
still win at the end of the day Jeremy
still wants to be me I do that'd be
awesome and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more for
free it's always great when movies like
priest & Legion come out free stuff for
you
I've gated that [ __ ] look probably
really gay